je pense que pour emmanuel macron hulot
c'est une marque elle a acheté la marque
mais n'a pas envie l'écologie quand le
ministre de l'agriculture parle on se
demande si c'est le miz de l'agriculture
en charge de l'intérêt général donc
dépositaire d'intérêt général ou les
lobby de l'agrobusiness et objectivement
c'est vrai que nicolas hulot a pas la
partie facile et quand même
on n'a jamais vu un gouvernement aussi
proche des lobbies celui-là lobby
bancaire lobby chimie que le lobby de
l'agrobusiness comme incroyable on est
bien supprimer l'impôt sur la fortune
aujourd'hui j'ai compris quelque chose
c'est que je pense que vous avez
remarqué que le gouvernement refuse de
donner le détail de l'impact de la
suppression d'impôt sur la fortune sur
les plus grandes fortunes françaises y
90 secret fiscal ce serait pure
coïncidence évidemment pure coïncidence
si la liste des grands bénéficiaires de
la suppression du lundi sf était aussi
la liste des gros donateurs à la
compagne d'emmanuelle macron qu'il a
également refusé de rendre public ce
serait pure coïncidence
vous écrivez enfin pression des lobbys
des riches et des lobbys très bas sur le
glyphosate emmanuel macron t le présent
des lobbys sur les banques et la dette
emmanuel macron et le président des
lobbys comme il était le ministre des
lobbys sur le lit sf et mais le
maquereau et le présent des réussites et
des lobbys mais ce je n'ai pas de doute
[Musique]